[Musique]
près de 6 millions de téléspectateurs
pour koh lanta vendredi soir et dans
l'épisode de vendredi la star c'est une
jeune fille qui s'appelle lola alors
depuis la réunification
la jeune ch'ti a survolé les épreuves
vous allez voir elle en a déjà remporté
trois sur huit et possède deux colliers
d'immunité
ça veut dire elles vont vers une
bijouterie en venant elle c'est un truc
de fou c'est comme regarder elle est
très très forte regardé son portefeuille
il m'appelle olaj fait étudiante en
master marketing option management et
j'habite à bergues dans le nord de la
france
une brèche si je vais vite parler aux
gens j'ai mes échanges
j'ai toujours le sourire puis un vrai
produit du nord mes parents ils ont une
friterie qui se situe juste en face de
la mer baraka tri c'est vraiment
l'ambiance chaleureuse des gens sont
agréables et c'est chaleureux c'est le
nord oui il pleut un peu mais on fait
avec on demande par aqmi alors lola
temps minable clientèle a cartonné
samedi soir bon vol il y en avait
vraiment que pour elle elle a survolé
les épreuves et as attendais pas à
gagner en même temps c'est un vrai
exploit physique pour elle voilà elle
fait joli et les sécurités regarder on
vous a fait un petit résumé elle est
impressionnante
le dernier obstacle la poutre nolan
ils ont touché le poteau vous remporter
ce jeu de confort et la récompense
les gars
[Musique]
et victoire
bravo lola
[Musique]
pour lola
si on vous avait dit au moment de la
réunification car ce stade de l'aventuré
vous auriez trois victoires j aurais
peut-être pas cru parce qu'après on est
sportif dans l'équipée
et ouais je m'impressionne un petit peu
là jamais ils ont l'air fatigué c'est
vrai que j'aurais aphatie ils sont beaux
ils sont cousins
c'est donc à les faire koh lanta un
visage pourquoi pourquoi ça carrément
technique est pourquoi il faut l'entamer
jamais de la vie je suis puni mois que
je n'ai au volet koh lanta mais je sais
pas je crois que j'aurais un peu la
niaque mais qu' une idée des moments je
me dire on n'y arrive pas j'ai mal j'en
ai marre je pourquoi je fais ça pourquoi
j'aurais dû écouter philippe gil a posé
pas bouffer déjà peut-être tous
remportés dames c'est vrai qu'il ya des
mecs quand même il reste huit heures
tuera un truc sur un bateau voilà oui
qu'un morceau de bois pour gagner chez
nous des losers ici alors il ya lola qui
a remporté l'épreuve de confort elle a
ainsi pu partir avec sa camarade et
meilleur ami dans le jeu angélique à la
découverte de la barrière de corail dif
1 les deux jeunes femmes ont également
eu droit à un véritable repas de rois à
base de poisson et fruits frais quand
elle rentre quand raconter leur journée
à leurs camarades font l'écho je me sens
vraiment s'animer en angoisse un danger
elles ont pu faire ça veut dire toi ces
calories en plus fait qui pourra
maintenant étudier à un mec
voilà mais il ya un mec qui vient tenir
chaud en train de me démontrer
un second petit truc pour nous deux
non
ce magnifique
pour à la réalité
on est arrivé avec tous les poissons et
où c'était magnifique on avait trois
énormes bout de poisson
on aurait du poulet est un poulet frites
on avait droit énorme où c'était un truc
gastro après raffiné non compensés et a
fait du bien mais nous on a trouvé un
plan de taro
ah ouais mais manger du poulet et peut
pas les regarder le pays
j'ai trouvé que c'était un
extraordinaire épisode parce qu'avais
l'aventuré la stratégie au sein de deux
ans cette année lawley dre sauvé sa
copine angélique qui aurait été éliminé
sans le collier que lola lui donne et
jusqu'à la fin du conseil on savait pas
franchement supervision prix 800 mille
tonnes et après deux menus en replay en
plus exactement ça fait 7 millions sur
moi c'est mon émission préférée bon je
vais pas cracher persie au seul regret
que c'est que sa peine ne soit plus une
émission de survie maintenant c'est club
med c'est un parc d'attractions on a
passé peut-être là quand on parle ils
sont fidji au soleil happe une mousse il
ya plus d'orage il fait beau et dans
bien oui ils sont jamais crevé il perd
des écoles en question posée à tous ici
pour demain je vous dis un truc
ouais j'étais tranquille téléspectateurs
tu es tranquille en train de dormir
j'ai eu chaud avec j'ai ouvert la
fenêtre 1 eh ben dis que je vais la tête
je me souviens bien il ya des moustiques
qui sont venus mais est-ce que les
moustiques
ils s'appellent entre eux il ya des gars
qui font des moulinets
il faut dégager des gains très attention
c'est bon il a ouvert la porte on peut y
aller tu vois il ya des mecs qui guette
comme ça dès que ségolène c'est parti
est ce que c'est vrai que le moustique
peut sentir la chair humaine à 50 km à
mr allure c'est que vous avez du sang
sucré salé a rien à voir
santes le sans sucre et devrait attirer
l'adversaire c'est l'odeur c'est l'odeur
et c'est pas la lumière souvent les gens
dit elle
méfiance aussi tommy temps-là tu sais
pas si je pense que ça intéresse les
gens
elle a décidé de donner l'un de ces deux
colliers d'immunité à sa meilleure amie
angélique est en grand danger
effectivement sans son collier angélique
a manqué de se faire éliminer
puisqu'elle a récolté quasiment autant
de voix contre elle que jodie donc voilà
à la sauve et angélique or maintenant on
peut se donner des colliers on va
bientôt tu vas révélé qu'une part aux
libertés quelqu'un souhaite il jouait ce
soir un collier d'immunité individuelle
fataliste mais pas suicidaire
j'ai joué un collégien
ensuite le dépouillement angélique
angélique angélique voici le dernier
bulletin
et il peut être décidé
joli
je dis prenez votre sac aller récupérer
votre flambeau et venez me rejoindre
[Musique]
ça veut dire qu'à l'idée est là oui
c'est le principe de contre attaque
anthony tu vas chercher pour ça que
c'est pas ton flow bout on veut plus
voir ses copains de sciences nat quoi
chercher vos affaires si tu pars dans la
forêt et là mon avis tu pense qu'à une
chose tu te dis je vais aller manger je
me faire un truc c est là c'est pas nous
c'est pas grave pour eux parce que là
comme ces îles sont réunis ils vont dans
un hôtel maintenant attendre la fin
d'épreuve donc ils sont calmes dans un
hôtel 3 étoiles quatre étoiles au bord
de la mer avec alors qu'avant la
réunification et rentrer à paris mais
moi j'attends les autres je vais les
voir stoppé fais moi plaisir liminaire
élimine moi j'ai rien faire il veut dire
si tu sors tout de suite la première
semaine tu passes tout le reste ce soir
alors depuis le début de l'aventuré il
ya la jeune havas qui est assez
abstraite ah oui on la voit quasiment
pas l'écran mais cette semaine tout la
candidate corse a fait parler d'elle
pourquoi parce qu'elle sait hippies des
couëts et oui elle s'épiler les
aisselles même ça sent pas très
particulière regardez pas d'une façon
dernière me regarder ça va vous rappeler
des souvenirs ici autour de la table je
sais qu'elle a beaucoup qui le font en
train de brûler un petit bout de bois
pour mettre en pratique une épilation
des aisselles avec les moyens du bord
juju des cheveux sous les bras donc ça
ne brûle pas la peau j'arrive à rester
assez loin
[Musique]
ça c'est un vieil transpire si je ne
crains pas c'est bien ouais mais en fait
ils sont tellement longs et je pue
tellement atroce que je n'aime pas mais
des fois je m'intéresse mais je le ferai
pas parce que ça m'est un peu égal
d'être poilus bouquet de ces fraudes
c'est une idée comme ça là bas c'est oui
ça doit sentir et grillé c'est génial
mais le foie gras ça donne rien ça donne
envie oui moi ça m'est arrivé
ça m'est arrivé une fois j'étais en
boîte de nuit et je me suis rendu compte
d'avoir nui j'avais un certain succès
avec une fille qui était là et tout d'un
coup j'ai eu comme un éclair de génie
j'ai oublié mes piles et du coup je
l'aiderai tous les thèmes de toilettes
de la boîte et puis c'est pile et
l'aigle à huy au briquet comme ça qu'on
n'est pas en direct parce que ça
seul et qu'on l'appelle dans le métier
maintenant la boule rouge donc koh lanta
il ya tellement rien à manger que le
moindre aliments donne l'impression
candidats qu'ils dégustent un truc de
ouf
là ils ont eu droit à deux carrés de
chocolat et 1,9 ouais t'as l'impression
qu'ils sont en train de manger leurs
meilleurs repas de noël ont fait deux
arrêts de gardien
oh là là les gars mais c'est la folle
difficile à laquelle choix à ce groupe 2
mon avis merci les poules on peut passer
des messages personnels
bien sûr j'ai un copain il vous
connaissez avec sa pelle bouder ils
regardent chaque année vous d'être bien
sûr mais c'est passionnant de regarder
un mec vous fait du fromage mais c'est
génial et chérie il ya un petit truc
alors qu'on est tous en galère avec le
confinement en france il y en a un qui
qui c'est denis brogniart qui est p
pousse à tahiti en polynésie française
regardez la vidéo du teaser de la
nouvelle saison à énerver beaucoup
regardé denis brogniart salut les amis
écouter je sais pas si vous êtes très
nombreux j'étais en tournage et je
pouvais pas être la plus plus tôt mais
regardez on est sur un petit mot tout en
polynésie et regardez comme c'est vous
regardez cet endroit absolument sublime
on a beau être en france on est sur les
petits îlots de l'autre côté de l'île de
ta que vous voyez derrière moi et je
suis content de vous apporter ça parce
que je sais que en métropole c'est
compliqué en ce moment sur l'île de
tahiti aussi
[Applaudissements]